[Music]
on this Sunday night Bloodshed on both
sides the shock and horror as Israel's
ground invasion of Gaza grows after that
surprise attack by
Hamas held hostage plus the Canadians
trapped with no way out our Jeff SLE is
in Israel tonight the chorus of
condemnation truly horrifying Israel has
a right to defend itself as the US
signals military report is being
mobilized also tonight rocket fire
launched from Lebanon Rising fears the
fighting will trigger a much wider
conflict global national with foreign
[Music]
Asser the sky over Israel tonight more
fire as another barrage of rockets is
fired from Gaza just a day after Hamas
launched a calculated and coordinated
surprise attack on Israel taking the
lives of hundreds of people and
triggering an Israeli Counterattack on
Palestinian territories killing even
more in the
crossfire good evening and thanks for
joining us fighting is Raging right now
in Israel and it is a fast moving
situation tonight Gaza itself is being
pounded by air strikes setting the stage
for a full-scale ground incursion by
Israel forces and the number of dead is
constantly Rising already more than 700
people have been killed on the Israeli
side and as many as 400 killed in
Palestinian territory Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
threatening to turn Gaza into a deserted
island tonight our reporters are
standing by on the ground in Israel in
Lebanon in the UK the US and here in
Canada all watching the developments
very closely let's go first to our Jeff
simple who's in Jerusalem tonight Jeff
what's the mood like there right
now far us some here in Dre Jerusalem
emerged from their homes today but
tensions remain high gun battles
continue tonight on Israeli territory
after an attack that people here are now
calling Israel's
9911 I feel the most vulnerable uh I've
ever felt in my life this Israeli and
former torontonian was one of thousands
who attended an overnight weekend music
festival near Israel's border with
Gaza he recorded this video just moments
before Rockets started raining
down because there's loud music you
don't really hear it but when you can
see the sky is like fireworks and I tell
my friend I'm like okay I think I think
we're getting bombed you know and as
soon as I said that the music cuts off
Israelis are used to hearing Rockets
from Gaza the vast majority are shot
down by Israel's Iron Dome but then he
heard a different
[Music]
noise suddenly gun from Gaza started
firing into the
crowd panicked partygoers scrambled in
all directions it was something of like
a movie scene when I was running away it
was like I felt like
prey um running away from a predator
many didn't make it some were murdered
as they tried to escape rescue crews
have recovered more than 250
bodies others were kidnapped now being
held hostage by Hamas
including this man's wife and two young
daughters I want to ask of Kamas don't
hurt
them don't hurt little children don't
women if you want me instead I'm willing
to come photos of people that are
missing right now this Nick JV swipes
through the faces of the missing
including several friends most likely
are dead or kidnapped you he and some
others escaped on foot and hid in a barn
it was several hours he says before he
saw anyone from the Israeli military
where are we you know we we're supposed
to be this strong military and like this
is and that was like
crazy after getting caught off guard
Israel's military is hitting back hard
mobilizing thousands of reservists and
formally declaring a state of War their
targets in Gaza have included a mosque
and apartment
buildings this mother says three of her
children are dead and a fourth is
missing after an Israeli rocket crashed
into their home she was trapped under
the rubble for
hours Israel blames Hamas for using
civilians as Shields the casualties
mounting on both sides to horrific
Heights not seen in decades it feels
unprecedented it doesn't feel real this
Israeli Canadian lives in Toronto and
came here last week to get
married but their honeymoon was
shortlived and I woke up at 7:00 in the
morning to my dad banging on our door
letting us know that air raid sirens had
gone off she and her extended family
sheltered for hours yesterday as
explosions and gunfire rumbled outside
I'm a third generation Holocaust
Survivor and today we have reports that
this is the single most amount of Jews
that have been murdered in a single day
since the Holocaust it seems
industrialized it's a massacre she's one
of several Canadians we spoke with here
today who is now desperately trying to
find a way out back to Canada afraid the
situation here will only get worse
far Jeff SLE in Jerusalem tonight thank
you for your coverage Jeff now there are
questions swirling about what the
Canadian government is doing to keep
Canadians in Israel safe and get those
who were trapped as Jeff just showed us
out Global flares Canada is aware of
reports of one Canadian who has died and
two others who are missing there are
more than 1,400 Canadians registered
with the state of Israel and almost 500
Canadians registered in the Palestinian
territories given the scope of the
violence and the Bloodshed there is
concern the number of Canadian
casualties could rise Tria isri
reports Hamas has taken a significant
number of people hostage including
Canadian citizens a respected
humanitarian and advocate for peace from
Winnipeg is now captive that's according
to Canada's former Justice Minister
Irwin C
he tweeted Canadian citizen Vivien
silver is being held by Hamas in a
standing War crime the administration at
a Vancouver High School is also fearful
for one of its former students who was
in Israel and hasn't been heard from
since the fighting erupted please say
extra prayers for King David alumnus Ben
Mahi class of 2018 who is attending an
event in the South and is missing Shauna
Austin is also from Vancouver and was in
Tel Aviv when moth launched the
carefully coordinated attack there's
been Sirens all night it shook the
building there's literally I was on the
floor on my hands and knees praying
crying telling my family like I love
them um it's just been really
hard Air Canada has temporarily canceled
flights to Israel leaving people like
Kendall and Marie Fullerton
stranded I would have thought that we
would have been getting more information
that the embassy would have you know con
gone to a a heightened sense of alert
and been able to advise Travelers a bit
better as to what we should be doing but
that's just you know not even an
email the Canadian embassy told them
it's closed until Tuesday for the
Thanksgiving weekend we had hoped that
they would send a repatriation flight
across to help Canadians get out of here
because everyone's stuck prime minister
Justin Trudeau has spoken to Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
expressing his deep condolences for the
hundreds of lives lost adding Canada is
Gravely concerned about the atrocities
that have been committed Canada's
ambassador to the United Nations is also
worried about a further escalation and
the ongoing hostage situation and has to
be resolved without using people as
blackmail or as human Shields and and
the second is the potential for
broadening the war despite the potential
for a broadening War it's not clear what
the Canadian government's exit strategy
is for Canadians who are trapped in the
region or what celor assistance Global
Affairs is providing
far Tria isri in Ottawa thank you Tria
now there is so much happening on the
ground in Israel and in Gaza tonight but
for Israel the danger isn't limited to
the Palestinian territories there was
shelling along Israel's northern border
with Lebanon today Israel has a long
history of conflict with Hezbollah in
Lebanon and Iran's government is
praising the deadly effectiveness of the
Hamas attacks in Gaza our crystal ganing
is in Beirut tonight with more on the
wider risks
Crystal far bayut is home to Hezbollah
an iran-backed political party and
militia that Canada and other Western
allies consider to be a terrorist group
and today we saw the first signs of
Hezbollah supporters itching to get
involved
dozens of rockets and shells rained down
on three Israeli positions in a disputed
part of Syria's isra occupied Golden
Heights on Sunday hasbalah saying the
volley was in solidarity with the
Palestinian
people the Israeli military returned
fire with Hezbollah reporting several
injuries Israeli tanks are rolling into
the region to shore up
defenses
at a rally in Beirut Hezbollah leaders
saying they salute Palestinian
resistance factions Hezbollah fought a
war with Israel in 2006 and tensions
have regularly flared
since praise for the Gaza attacks is
also coming from Iran with fireworks in
the
streets and lawmakers chanting death to
Israel we haven't yet seen Direct
evidence that Iran was behind this
particular attack or involved but the
the support over many years is
clear the Gaza attacks are a major
setback for peace efforts in the region
just last month at a meeting in New York
the Israeli Prime Minister and US
president seemed optimistic about
forging new ties in the region working
on a diplomatic deal with Saudi Arabia I
think that uh under your leadership Mr
President we can forge a historic peace
between Israel and Saudi Arabia and I
think such a peace would go a long way
first to advance the end of the Arab
Israeli conflict uh achieve
reconciliation between the Islamic world
and the Jewish State and Advance a
genuine peace between Israel and the
Palestinians the negotiations had
included Israeli concessions to the
Palestinians in addition to US security
guarantees and civilian nuclear help
sought by Saudi Arabia it's no surprise
that those opposed to the efforts to
normalize relations between Saudi Arabia
and Israel and more broadly uh to
normalize Israel's relations with
countries uh throughout the region and
Beyond who opposes it uh Hezbollah Hamas
uh and and Iran so to the extent that
this was designed to try to derail the
efforts that were being made um that
speaks volumes Anthony blinkin the US
Secretary of State was going to discuss
all of this with the Saudi Crown Prince
next week during a regional tour Saudi
Arabia is now calling for restraint and
urging the International Community to
activate a credible process leading to a
two-state solution between Israel and
the Palestinians Farah Crystal
commanding in Beirut thank you
Crystal from the United States to the
Vatican many world leaders are
expressing their support for Israel even
as concerns rise over how this conflict
could escalate even further Joel senic
reports
the state of war in the Middle East
reverberating across the world in
Washington Flags fly at half staff on
Capitol Hill a show of solidarity with
Israel the US government moving Navy
ships and aircraft closer to the country
as new details emerge of Americans
caught in the conflict we've got reports
that several Americans are among the
dead we're working very actively to
verify those reports at the same time
the reports of Americans being taken
hostage there too the Revelation comes
as Israel's allies continue to condemn
hamas's surprise attack the scenes that
we've seen in Israel over the past 36
hours are truly horrifying of course
people are worried about escalation but
Israel has a right to defend itself and
and it will be doing so in Ukraine a
sign of support is President Vladimir
zinski urging the world to stand with
Israel while Germany's chancellor
expressed shock and
outrage at the Vatican Pope Francis
calling for an end to the fighting and
praying for peace in the region in
Israel in Palestina the UN Security
Council met Sunday to discuss the
conflict its humanitarian officials are
pleading for the creation of corridors
to bring food into Gaza as Israeli air
strikes Target the area attacks that
many expect will intensify the state of
Israel cannot allow what has happened to
stand and we cannot give in this kind of
extortion this is in essence a battle
for pretty much for National survival
and to help in that battle us officials
say in addition to Military Support they
will also send equipment and resources
to the region the Biden Administration
says Israel can expect more assistance
in the days ahead Joel senic Global News
Washington Israel's anticipated
retaliation and Beyond coming out the
escalating War reverberating across the
[Music]
world Israel has vowed Revenge Israeli
Defense Forces have hinted at widening
their response to strike against
iran-backed Hezbollah in Lebanon now
that could lead to a large escalation in
the Middle East as Redmond Shannon
reports whatever option Israel chooses
will have difficult
consequences as night fell on Gaza the
retribution continued true to Israeli
promises Israeli
intelligence indicates that Hamas are
hiding among gazan civilians inside
gazan homes and schools hospitals and
masks the Israeli government says more
than 100 hostages are now held inside
Gaza the only way to get them out soon
would be by force Israel is right now in
the midst of conducting maybe completing
preparation for a a large
scale uh military ground operation in
Gaza Street AI mamed is a former Israeli
intelligence official he says any ground
operation would see large casualties
military and civilian in many different
aspects this is an
enormously uh complicated challenge if
Israeli forces do enter Gaza ramped up
operations may not be confined to this
small strip of land tensions would
likely rise in the occupied West Bank
too and Israel has hinted it may also
look to strike against iran-backed
Hezbollah forces in Lebanon Hezbollah is
a totally different ball game we are
looking at capacities that are tripled
if not quadrupled compar comparing to
both Hamas and Islamic J
combin Hezbollah leaders have said they
stand with Palestinians in Gaza but the
rocket fire they exchanged with Israel
has so far been tokenistic according to
Middle East analyst Sami Hamdi and I
think that if the gazans had hoped that
this could be enter into a wider
conflict I think they are bitterly
disappointed at the stance of those they
expected to be allies including the
stance of hisbah itself SOI believes
International pressure on Israel could
avert a wider conflict too it may well
be that we're heading toward Wards talks
and negotiations as the Palestinians
believe they've already achieved a
victory and now it's about trying to
secure that vine negotiations and
possible concessions from the Israelis
any negotiations could eventually
involve a huge prisoner swap deal in
2011 Hamas handed back one Israeli
soldier for over ,000 Palestinian
prisoners a deal that was both very
controversial and took five years to
broker far Redmond Shannon in London
thank you Redmond
ah had ravaged by Conflict for decades
the natural disaster that has now killed
thousands in
[Music]
[Applause]
Afghanistan a police officer opened fire
on a tourist bus in Alexandria killing
at least two Israelis and their Egyptian
tour guide officials say one other
person was injured and that the
suspected shooter was arrested Egypt was
the first first Arab country to make a
peace deal with Israel in the 70s but
experts say an anti-israel sentiment
still exists in parts of
Egypt in Afghanistan more than 2,000
people are now known to have died in two
powerful
earthquakes one of the Tremors a 6.3
magnitude Quake rattled the region on
Saturday leveling at least 12 villages
in the country's harat Province near the
Iranian border Rescuers are frantically
searching for survivors trapped beneath
the rubble 9,000 people have been
injured next how the hostages being held
in Gaza are complicating Israel's next
[Music]
steps as the situation continues to
develop in the Middle East joining us
now is Steven Simon a former White House
Middle East adviser for both the Clinton
and Obama administrations he's now with
the Quincy Institute thanks so much for
joining us Mr Simon now some are calling
this Israel's 9/11 and of course when
9/11 happened there was a seismic shift
in the world you've actually written
books about this what are the possible
consequences of the past 24
hours well the first possible
consequence is a wher war uh if Lebanese
hisbah decides to intervene on hamas's
behalf uh there are unconfirmed reports
that hisbah has reached out to the
Egyptians in a back channel to say that
if the Israelis go into Gaza on the
ground then hisbah will uh
intervene uh I emphasize that that's um
unconfirmed uh but it's plausible uh the
initial hisb response uh to hamas's uh
request that it intervene in the
conflict was
standoffish uh uh but uh but that could
change and the Israelis now seem to be
uh beginning the evacuation process
process from towns and Villages along
the northern border of Israel with
Lebanon you mentioned Hamas has taken
hostages there reports some are being
held in tunnels so how does that
complicate Israel's response right now
well uh Israel's First Option uh is to
uh reach out to Hamas through
intermediaries uh to attempt um uh to
liberate the hostages uh diplomatically
through back Channel negotiations uh
probably managed by uh the Egyptians uh
in the past that hasn't worked out all
that well uh Hamas tends to hold on to
its Israeli hostages and and Israeli
bodies uh bodies of of killed Israelis
for quite a long time looking for the
most opportune moment to cash in on them
uh freeing the hostages militarily I I
think will be uh difficult if not
impossible because the hostages are uh
dispersed and they're hidden as you've
pointed out uh so uh that's going to be
an obstacle uh for uh for Israel and
right now I'm sure they're debating in
the inner councils uh of their
government uh whether uh their military
operation operations should be
constrained um by a u uh a desire to
ensure the hostages are not killed in
the process of Israeli operations and
that's a very tough decision for the
Israeli government to make Stephen Simon
with the Quincy Institute thanks for
your time thank you very
much and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm far Nasser and we want
to leave you tonight with more scenes of
the aftermath in Gaza and Israel as the
violence between both sides rages on in
a weekend that will go down in history
our coverage of the violence continues
tomorrow until then take care of
yourselves and each other good
night
[Music]